[موسيقى]
الحل الذي يمكن ان يزيل مثل هذه
النتائج التي شاهدناها والتي لا تزال
قائمه هو اندماج تلك الاذرع المسلحه في
مشروع في مشاريع دولها ان تندمج وان تصبح
خاضعه
[موسيقى]
لمنطق الدوله
وان تصبح علاقات ايران مع من دوله الى
دوله وليس من خلال هذه الاحزاب ومن خلال
تلك الازرع والمنظمات
[موسيقى]
ينبغي وهذا ما كنا نطلبه قديما ان المطلوب
من ايران ان تتعاطى مع لبنان او مع العراق
او مع اليمن ان تتعاطى مع دول تلك
الشعوب مباشره وليس من خلال احزاب
وتنظيمات وجمعيات
يعني نحن الان لا يمكننا ان نحكم على
النوايا وانما نحكم من خلال الممارسات وما
سيحدث بعد تنفيذ هذه البنود
وانا متفائل بانه ستتغير الكثير من الامور
لان ايران قد ادركت يعني بانما كان من
اسباب الفرقه بينها وبين
جيرانها واشقائها في العالم العربي
والاسلامي هو تلك السياسه
التي اعتمدت منطق الازرع
المسلحه في اكثر من منطقه
[موسيقى]